Hello and welcome to this next video. For this we will be going through another example and
we're going to be having a quick look at the world gray it query node. So for this example
we are on slide three example three projection. This is actually slightly different from the
projection node itself which is usually used to make things stick to the floor if you're
working above it. However what we are looking at here is the world hit ray query. And so this is a
different method of getting our first starting points because what we've been using up to this
point is splines and landscape materials. In this example we're doing it in a slightly different way.
What we're doing is we're using the world ray hit query combined with a filter
so that we can see that we're only looking for factors which are including the filter
vines. It's going to ignore everything else. And if we have a look into the level of how
this looks you can see that we have a whole load of different vines that are hanging off of
these different static meshes. It's a nice way of getting stuff on things because we're not always
going to be working with landscapes and you might want to put stuff on the bottom of meshes
or on the top of meshes and the world ray is a good method of doing that. In this case it's
not a perfect example but it gives you sort of an idea of how you can go about it. Just hanging
a bunch of vines in on the meshes as they are. So a quick look at it what we have is our origins
and then we got the world direction and it's going to do a whole load of lines out from
that point. A bit like how the direct light functions. It's like doing lots and lots of
line traces which is kind of the same thing the projection node does as well.
In this I'm using the landscape as a cut out so that we can not create the vines too low down.
Okay and that's it. A nice quick one. Did you find that useful?